well this weekend is seeing senior
royals visiting all four uk nations this
morning crowds in belfast greeted the l
and countess of wessex with a very warm
welcome prince edward and sophie are
visiting northern ireland as part of the
queen's platinum jubilee celebrations
well joining me now is our senior island
correspondent david blevins uh david
just remind us where you are and what's
been going on there today
yes jane welcome back to banggood and
county down where there is a terrific
celebration going on to mark the
platinum jubilee vehicles from all seven
decades vintage fairground attractions
and music and dancing to take us all
back in time now this was the second of
two engagements for the royal couple
today first of all they went to belfast
city center appropriately arriving in
royal avenue in front of city hall where
they were able to partake in a very
multicultural celebration there was all
sorts of belfast busking bans a chinese
dragon dance and some music from a band
consisting of irish indian african and
polish musicians so a truly
multicultural affair and then they made
their way over here to bangor on the
north down coast not just to mark 70
years of queen elizabeth but also the
fact that this time has just been
designated city status they seemed very
relaxed despite the obvious security
that housed us around this kind of event
in northern ireland stopped to chat to
many people in the crowd i asked his
royal highness if he was glad to be back
in northern ireland he replied yes and
thank you for the weather which i think
suggests as is often the case it wasn't
quite so sunny on the last visit he made
to northern ireland but there has been a
very warm welcome
for edward and sophie in both belfast
and bangor as northern ireland plays its
part in marking this platinum jubilee
this weekend